first I want to thank Jess because one
thing that you should do when you're
organizing a conference is to give
somebody a data analysis task which is
really really important to the
conference it involves web scraping and
telling somebody who tell anybody who
the winner is
I wasn't stressful at all um but no
seriously it was like yeah so before I
get started I wanted to bring like you
know it's hard to follow Maura because
you know she's outgoing and I'm like
dirty but I don't want to get serious
like too much at first but there was
like something like something really
important that came up yesterday I mean
it has to be addressed so we were
talking about snakes and and it came up
into the talks and so you know no one's
saying like I kind of want the name the
snake right and so I have so I have some
expertise here that we we just got a
ball python and my son decided to name
it doodle ramen noodle so I like the
thing that were really good at naming
animals so if you need another long name
for a pet let me know and we'll hook you
up anyway he did make the party hat so
yeah alright so what are we here to talk
about or what am I here to talk about
we're here to talk about modeling and
resampling which should be no surprise
anybody since it's me so what I want to
talk about is how do you measure
performance between models I do a lot of
predictive modeling like machine
learning stuff and that's really where I
focus but the the stuff that I've talked
about here is really really represented
you could use this on anything I have
examples on the website for like you
know basic survival models and things
like that but I want to talk about a way
to use a kind of an odd way to use
Bayesian analysis to take different
models in say in practical ways which
one's better or how different they are
so it's a way to quantify model
performance okay so a lot of times you
know we get this data set and we build
some models maybe build like three
models and at the end of the day we want
to say oh this one is better than that
one so we compute some sort of measure
performance like the accuracy or the air
into the or C curve or maybe you're
doing leading regression would you like
r-squared or something like that and so
we usually have like you know if you
follow like the machine learning
approach good idea is to take your data
set and split it off into a training set
which you built
and a test set which you wait till the
very end to evaluate the amount of
performance on so two different sets of
data and you know the question is when I
have a test set and I calculate like the
I don't know like the R squared
you know you might when some sort of
measure of uncertainty on that so let's
say you get an R squared for one model
that's 0.9 and another model it's a
point 9 one like okay that's a
percentage point higher like is that a
big deal you know is that better should
I you know because it might be that the
the one at the lower R squared is a
model you like more for various reasons
like maybe it's really fast or some like
that so so a lot of times what we want
to do is we would put estimates of
uncertainty on this I kind of a
confidence and Ellora some like that on
the R squared so we can say like yeah
these two things are really different or
they're not but the problem is you have
like one data set and for the most part
unless you're going to do some
bootstrapping and things like that it's
really hard to put estimates of noise on
these things and then compounded with
that is like traditional like
frequentist or non Bayesian approach to
doing this would be like to put a
confidence in all these numbers I just
want to remind everybody like what a
confidence enroll actually is which is
basically you know if I were to have
repeated this experiment in some
alternate reality like a thousand times
you know a 90% confidence overall you
would say 90% of those times the value
would fall between these two numbers
so try telling that to like a scientist
or somebody they're like what like what
are you talking about and that's not
really what we care about what they what
they typically interpret that as is
something like saying well there's a 90%
probability that the true r-squared is
between these two values and those are
two very different things
but luckily Bayesian analysis and
credible intervals and things like that
will give you the latter more simple
interpretation where you get an interval
and it's really the the probability a
certain degree probability that the true
values between two numbers based on your
assumptions and so that's you know I'm
not like full-scale Bayesian yet but I'm
getting there I feel like there's some
things I still couldn't do with that and
I was really hoping this talk wasn't
following Gelman or but even worse
before yeoman so yeah so I want to use
some Bayesian analysis and to do that
and so let's see how it goes but before
we get there we got to talk about data a
little bit so a lot of time we can
resample datasets so we have you ever
heard of cross-validation the bootstrap
what people will do is they'll take a
training set their data and they'll do
this
sampling procedures that like basically
our Catholic simulation procedures they
with some methodology leave out somewhat
random proportion of the data and you
build a model on that and the data that
you didn't use to build the model is
what you predict on and get your
measures of performance your summary
statistics and then you put them all
back in the pot and you do like another
resample and so on so you're basically
taking like simulated subsets of your
data that you build your model on and
then you predict on the other set that
was left out and at the end of the day
if you do let's say ten iterations of
your sampling you get like ten R
Squared's and it turns out that the
average of those usually is a good
measure of future performance okay so
that's what all resampling is it's a way
usually to get measures of performance
on the data set before you get to your
test set okay which is computationally
can be kind of a lot sometimes but it's
extremely helpful and so this is just a
little schematic of like how we use our
data we get you know somebody brings us
a CSV file or like a few minutes ago
some he says please scrape these two
websites to tell me what's going on so
you got all your data and typically
people separate it into a training set
and a test set and the resampling
happens on the training set and so you
can see you probably wouldn't do three
resamples that's not very much but
that's what I could fit on this page and
so like on the first three sample there
on the left now I sort of tried to
invent some terminology a few like last
year because people talk about the
training and test setting resampling and
then it gets confused with the original
training in test set so what I've
decided to do is to call these things
that happen in resampling the analysis
set which is what you build your model
on is like the resampled version of your
training set and the assessment set is
like your resampled version of the test
set okay so on the first resample you
take a little bit of data you build a
model that's the analysis set and then
you predict what's in the assessment set
and you put it back in and then the next
resample has maybe a similar or maybe
mutually exclusive set of data that's in
the analysis set and so on okay so the
different types of cross-validation or
the different types of resampling
cross-validation to bootstrap they
mainly differ and how those resamples
are created okay so what happens is
let's say you're going to build a bunch
of models let's say you're doing
regression you're going to build four
models so what people typically do is
they would take those four models and
they would fit them
each time on each one of these resamples
and so then you know for this first
analysis set on the left
you know you'd fit your four different
models and you get four different
predictions on the assessment set which
would rely resulting like four different
R Squared's and so that's what happens
when you do resampling is the first
iteration of resampling you get these
four estimates of R squared the second
estimate you get four different
estimates of R squared that are all
based on the assessment set and so on so
you go to sort of round robin and again
your overall estimate of performance for
the first model would be the average of
those are squares across all the
resamples okay so here's the thing is
like if you don't do resampling and you
want to build some sort of probabilistic
statement about like hey my performance
on this model is you know 90% R squared
plus or minus something you kind of need
replicas right does anybody ever come to
me with the data set and they're like
did you analyze this so it's like one
number I mean that's kind of where we're
at if we don't do resampling so what we
do is we use resampling which we might
be doing anyway to tune models as a way
to get replicates of this thing we're
trying to measure and get uncertainty
for and that's how this happens and so
what we end up with is sort of like a
two-way layout basically so this is I
have post all the code in all this this
is the Ames housing data set has anybody
ever heard that I'm hoping like in five
years it'll be the next iris set or in
the next empty cars because I'm so tired
of it
but it's a data set that it was from
like 2013 that this guy basically
scraped the website of the Iowa
assessor's office and and it was using a
casual competition and so we put an R
package together for it and basically
we're trying to predict sale prices of
houses and I'm not going to go into the
models or what I did or what I didn't do
but what you would do in this resampling
process is I use 10-fold
cross-validation which means we have ten
separate resamples instead of three like
I should know the last page and what
you'll see is there are rows for each
one of these resamples so this is using
the our sample package so fold one is
the first resample full two's a second
and then I fit a bag tree random forests
and a multivariate adaptive regression
spinal to these data so in the first
fold these are the R Squared's that we
calculated for the assessment set the
first time around the secondary sample
here are the assessments
our Squared's and so on so we have like
a full data matrix and so if you think
about this as kind of your source data
at this point like if somebody brought
you in an OVA model like it would look
like this the only real difference is
the data the things that we've measured
that we want to analyze now is not the
original sale price data it's the actual
R Squared's which are what are in this
table okay so now we're going to analyze
the summary statistics of our models as
if they were our original data or at
least the data that we want to get
performance measures on and contrast
against different walls so we can treat
this like an ANOVA model the
complication here is that there's
usually a bunch of what we call resample
to resample effect is you might have one
resample that all the models have
trouble with so it's almost uniformly
low performance and then you might have
another model that was really easy on
and then you have a bunch of things in
between so my observation is it's kind
of like a mixed model or like if you
have longitudinal data that the data
within a reefs and pool is more likely
to be correlate with each other than
data between resamples and so actually
you can calculate this from like a mixed
model or like the Bayesian model do in a
minute and the within resample
correlation is 0.5 - which is pretty you
know not zero most likely and you know
and what you can see is in this graph on
the next page these the same data and
what I did is each line is a resample
and then you have the bagged model the
marsh model and rain of forests and you
can see that surprisingly like bagging
didn't do all that well considering it's
very similar to rain of forests but what
the thing to notice about this in terms
of the correlation structure is that
we're good let's call this mob maybe
yeah okay
mob you know that resample was really
really easy for everybody and then you
have some down here like this
teal cyan maybe that one that you know
was relatively low for everybody and and
so the lines are not always parallel
these are roughly parallel there's some
of these resamples that are not like
rank order the same way but you can see
there is probably correlation structure
there that we need to account for in the
data like we would with a compare t-test
okay so any analysis of these r-squared
values ought to account for that and so
we'll do that as we go along so here's
the mathy part and i don't think it's
too bad that if we were just thinking
about
like an ANOVA model the typical way you
would write that down we have some like
outcome you want to model as a function
of some indicator variables like are you
in Group 1 or group 2 group 3 and so the
math is on the left hand side we have R
squared which is like our data now and
then we have an intercept and then we
have M 1 and M 2 which would be
indicators for our models like binary
indicators so M 1 might be an indicator
for the Mars model and MT might be the
zr1 indicator for random forests and
this is basically what an ANOVA model is
it's like a regression on indicator
variables now I haven't really talked
about you know the resamples there's no
like subscripts or I or anything like
that
so the way you can think about this is
what we call random intercept model is
we're gonna say like at the wreath at
the resample level for a specific reason
pillai k-- are square roots of i that
they have some random intercept that
puts them somewhere on that curve and
then a non systematic effect due to like
model one and model two okay so what
we're gonna do is do what we call in
like if anybody is like a linear mixed
model person like a random intercept
model this is a really common like way
to account for correlation and data so
the the sort of generative model here is
that we're gonna have effects due to the
models but like a random intercept and
that would account for this effect like
you know if we can think of these curves
as having roughly the same pattern but
it just shifts up and down depending on
the resample that's like a random
intercept model in it and i didn't pick
that because it happened to work out
this way this is really really typical
for these types of datasets so what i'm
going to do is i want to fit a bayesian
hierarchical generalized linear model
it's a lot of words and what that means
is the r-squared is going to be a
function we're going to say it's let's
say it's normally distributed with some
random intercept beta 0 and some you
know systematic effects for the models
in sums Sigma squared and so what we
would do in the Bayesian analysis is we
would put prior distributions on these
parameters and it's pretty common to and
that's what makes it a Bayesian model is
we're saying that there's a statistical
distribution these parameters prior to
seeing the data and then what Bayesian
analysis does is it blends those prior
distributions with the actual data we
collected and merges them to some degree
together to get what they call the
Syrio distribution and i had a bunch of
titles for this talk that kind of got
rejected because there's a lot you can
do it's posterior as the title but what
this comes down to is we get like a
random intercept model so we can account
for the the within correlation problem
and then treat it like it's a linear
model right so we're gonna model the R
squared DT now so that works pretty well
so I have this package called Teddy
posterior that does this and it
basically uses stand to fit the model
and there's a lot of flexibility in
terms of how you do this so when I first
started thinking about doing this I
thought well jeez I have r-squared value
you know that's probably know this are
bounded between zero and one so you know
I probably shouldn't assume normality
about that right that's probably not a
good idea but it turns out in many cases
not this particular one but you're okay
using normality and the idea is like the
central limit theorem we think of is as
we start looking at averages of data
points no matter what their distribution
is right central limit theorem tells it
that those averages as a data gets
bigger tend to convert to something that
looks more normal and basically our
squared root mean squared error things
like that are almost like averages of
our individual data points so they tend
to behave pretty well so you know there
are times where you might want to change
the link function or you might want to
assume gamma distribution you can do all
that in the package what I did here was
the R squared values in some cases were
relatively close to one and so what I
didn't want to do is have my posterior
distribution saying you could have an R
squared of point you know one point
something so what I did is I I pre
transform the data on a loaded scale so
loggia would basically translate the 0-1
values to you know potentially negative
infinity and infinity and then do the
data analysis on that and then and so
that's what the Bayesian analysis is on
is like the loge of the R squared values
and then the cool thing is when you get
your posterior distributions back you
could just untransformed to get back to
the original unit so it doesn't relie
cost you anything and that and my
experience is that is better than using
a low jet link or something because just
convergence is more difficult that way
so here's the result so what what
happens is you get these distributions
for these models and you can see these
violin plots which we're having dinner
like yesterday or last night and it
heightens like I hate violin plots I'm
like oh
good thing he's not here right so what'd
you get out of this is you get like
these posterior distributions so you can
see the bagged model has a pretty wide
variance and maybe let's say it's the
center that distributions about like
0.79 so you know it maybe didn't do so
well but then for Mars and random
forests we ran on forces doing a little
bit better but just by a little bit
maybe and those distributions are a
little bit tighter the reason for the
difference in variation between those
distributions is because I put it on the
logit scale so you do a low jat normal
model basically when you transform it
back you're not going to get a
necessarily symmetric data and it makes
sense because the you know for something
between zero one you would think that
the variability in that statistic is
higher in the middle because as you
start pushing more and more closer to
zero one those distribution should get
compacted to some degree so it's a it's
a fairly realistic at least to me it
seems like it makes a lot of sense so
what you can do is if you wanted to say
okay well let's say I like random
forests you can basically get credible
intervals by looking let's say
percentiles of these distributions and
you can say oh you know my random forest
model I think the true performance is
about you know eight point eighty nine
point one percent it could have been as
high as like knotty point five percent
if it's like 90 percent interval or it
could have been you know with the 90
cent property bode could have been as
low as eighty seven point eight all
right so let's you what's cool about
this is it lets you make comments
directly about the thing that you want
instead of like a confidence interval or
even worse like what a p-value would
give you it's like you have these like
convoluted interpretations or the things
we're trying to get to so the thing
about it is that you know I said in the
title practical differences and so you
know is you know if I'm comparing Mars
and random forests you know that's like
it may be a one point something percent
difference in our square is that a
practical difference is it real so what
we can do is once we get the posteriors
for these things it's really really easy
to get the posterior of the difference
in r-squared okay and so what you can do
is now you can think about well when I
want to compare models I can get like a
Bayesian estimate of the difference in R
squared between these models and then
maybe put an interval on that okay so
what we can do is we can do some things
with the R squared now there's this idea
of like a rope estimate and so a rope
rope stands for region of practical
equivalence and what these people
thought of is
well let's say I put something before
start modeling I say okay you know I'm
looking at r-squared for house prices
what would be like if I had two models
without seeing the data if I two models
how big of an R squared difference what
I want to see to say that's a real
difference right and that's really
subjective so you might say one percent
so you might say five percent I decided
to say two percent so if let's say I had
a model it was like r-squared was like
point seven eight another one that was
point eight you know two percent
difference is probably practical enough
for me to feel like that's a real thing
okay it depends she just looked at me
like sketchy like a sigh died me she was
like no no no so but it is it is
subjective but what you can do is once
we get the posterior for the difference
between these things you can look at it
in terms of what is a two percent
difference realistic given the results
that we have and a big part of that's
the uncertainty that we're collecting so
if we're looking at random force versus
Mars here's what the posterior
difference or the the posterior of the
difference in our square between those
two models it is slightly positive
because our random force does a little
bit better than Mars you can see the
tails of it maybe are around like I
don't know point point maybe oh three or
negative point of three it's roughly
symmetric if we were looking at
statistical significance like the old
school sort of significance we calculate
maybe how much of that distribution what
percentage of that probability
distribution is to the right of zero
right so that's saying is there any
difference between these models and you
could calculate that probability really
easily with the posterior but what the
dotted lines are the region of practical
equivalence and what that means is how
much of the posterior distribution is
within this plus or minus two percent
that I think is like within that two
percent it's not a real difference and
so what people typically do is they
calculate the percentage of the
posterior that's inside those bounds so
what they would say is in this
particular case ninety three point five
percent of that posteriors within plus
or minus two percent so we'd say the
probability of practical equivalence
between these two models given sort of
like the yardstick of two percent
there's really really high so based on
that sort of measure of what I think a
real difference is you would probably
conclude there's nothing different
between these two models right so you
would say it's not a big enough
difference for me to think it's you know
maybe it's statistically significant but
it's not practical equivalent and this
might be a big deal because if you're
about this Mars is a really really easy
model to put in let's say Excel or
whatever you want the prediction
equation that's really nice
whereas random force comes with you know
thousands of trees that have maybe
hundreds of splits and things like that
so you might have like a much faster
implementation of your prediction
equation that you've you know could
probably feel pretty good about it
having equal uncertainty or equal
performance to this other model okay so
that's all it does so basically the
package is called Teddy posterior and I
did it using results from this other
package called our sample that we've
written it also works with carrots so if
you're using carrot if you've used
carrot there's this much code resamples
that collects all the resampling results
and analyzes it this is like the you
know resamples with like mag wheels it's
like the badass version of resamples and
it basically works the same way but
gives you different analysis results
that's
[Applause]
you